they're introducing third world
practices of exploitation in the first
world
vote no on this corporate power grab
we're not getting benefits
and i knew that coming into this i like
the flexibility should americans be
allowed to freelance
progressive democrats have been pushing
legislation at the state and federal
level that would force companies like
uber and lyft in particular
to make all of their independent
contractors full-time employees
would you like to see this
california-based
law go nationwide well of course but
that movement had a major setback in the
2020 election when california voters
came out in favor of severely limiting
the impact of a 2019 law that as it was
originally written
would have wiped out the state's
freelance economy california voters
appear to have approved
proposition 22. assembly bill 5 had
already been weakened by several
carve-outs but a referendum on the 2020
ballot was the biggest blow to the
bill's original intent
because it means that uber and lyft
drivers will be mostly exempt from its
requirements
back in may joe biden called attempts to
gut ab5
unacceptable urging californians to vote
no on the referendum
nevertheless in this overwhelmingly blue
state almost 60 percent approved the
measure at the ballot box
when reason covered ab5 earlier this
year its most vocal opponents turned out
to be freelance writers on both the left
this goes too far and right they're
politicians
they're union workers they're people who
don't get it they're activists
they're cutting people off from
opportunity it didn't occur to
california lawmakers that many
freelancers actually prefer the
flexibility that comes with being an
independent contractor
companies like box which wrote articles
in support of ab5 cut its staff of
independent contractors because it
couldn't afford to bring them on full
time
labor activists and progressive
lawmakers were in effect deciding on
behalf of workers that if they couldn't
have a full-time job with benefits
they would be better off not having a
job at all for us this is about focusing
on ensuring that jobs
have are good jobs right if we have one
or a hundred jobs that are paying
less than minimum wage there is
absolutely no benefit
we i rather have you know 50 good jobs
than a hundred
bad paying jobs and those 50 good jobs
are actually giving a living wage
although the law applied to freelance
writers its real targets were gig
economy startups like uber lyft and
doordash
uber and lyft said that if ab5 were
enforced as originally written
it would cost hundreds of thousands of
drivers their jobs
and may even force the companies to shut
down operations in california
basically this is a unions versus
independent workers
struggle the unions are declining except
public employees unions and so they're
desperately thrashing around for people
that they can organize
williamson evers is a political
scientist and a senior fellow at the
independent institute a libertarian
think tank in oakland california he says
that uber and lyft weren't bluffing when
they said they'd leave california
if you say well in california it's just
going to be a sinkhole
nothing but expense and red tape and
crazy labor costs that are not going to
be true in other places
why go there if drivers are forced to
become employees
up to 90 of app-based driving jobs could
disappear
the ride-sharing company spent more than
200 million dollars on proposition 22
trying to convince california voters to
exclude them from ab5
while the law's opponents spent roughly
20 million dollars
proponents of ab5 attribute their defeat
to the fact that they were outspent
i don't think money determines political
outcomes it has an effect on them in
2016
hillary clinton vastly outspent donald
trump and she lost anyway
it's not really determinative the prop
22 people had the better argument
and they took advantage of what they had
to make their case to the people i hope
that there's some way that the labor
movement can
look at freelancers of all types and say
this is a valid
honorable profession that we are workers
too
many of us choose this field we are not
exploited we're not scabs we're small
businesses
and we deserve to be treated that way
the real exploitation
is the thing that forces people to work
hours
they don't want to work and in ways they
don't want to work
you